In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 26 on which we commemorate,
the Holy Hieromarter Basileus, Bishop of Amacia.
On the 26th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hieromarter, Basil,
Bishop of Amacia and of St. Claferra.
Our Holy Father Basil exceeded to the Episcopal Sea of Amacia in Pontus
during the Great Persecution under Diocletian, Galerius and Maximino's Daya.
Both by preaching and example, he showed that a Christian must always be ready to shed his blood for Christ.
Then, at the end of the bloody repression, he confirmed the churches of Pontus in the faith,
took part in the councils of Ankara and Neo-Cessaria in the year 314,
and taught the faithful how to guard themselves from heretics.
The conversion of St. Constantine and his assumption of power in the West
appeared to have proclaimed the end of persecution in the year 312.
The devil, though, found in Licinius in the years 308 through 325,
an instrument for his purpose.
Of lowly origins, Licinius had, through his military talents, acquired mastery over the Danube lands,
and after having recognized Constantine's sovereignty and married his sister Constantia,
was sent to Nicomedia to put an end to the cruelties of Maximino's Daya.
But, having overthrown Maximinos, he seized power over the Eastern Empire
and showing his true face, set himself with all his being against the disciples of Christ.
His wife had a beautiful and chased Christian handmaid, Glaphira, to whom Licinius was attracted,
seeking to satisfy his passion at any price.
Informed of this by a courtier, Glaphira told Constantia about it.
In order to trick the emperor, she spread the rumor that her handmaid had succumbed to a sudden attack of epilepsy
and sent her, dressed in men's clothing, to Amesia.
Glaphira was there paternally welcomed by Saint Basil, and she gave him a large sum of money, with which to build a church.
When she wrote to her mistress, to give her the news and ask her help in completing the building,
the letter was intercepted and came to Licinius' knowledge.
He immediately sent armed men to Amesia, with orders to arrest both the young woman and Bishop Basil.
But, when the soldiers arrived in Amesia, they learned that Glaphira had given her soul into God's hands some days earlier.
They seized Basil and took him, bound like a lamb, for the slaughter, and followed by two deacons,
filthimos and parthenios.
Once arrived in Nicomedia, Saint Basil had a divine revelation in prison that told him the manner of his coming martyrdom,
and the name of his successor.
The next morning, he appeared before Licinius, who impressed by his serenity and the majesty of his bearing, left the chamber,
leaving the prefect of Nicomedia to finish the interrogation.
He suggested to Basil that they pass over the matter of Glaphira, and he would not only preserve his life,
but give him the title of Supreme Pontiff, on condition that he agreed to honor the gods of the empire,
like every good Roman citizen.
The holy bishop then spoke, and recalling to the pagans all the horrors and vile acts committed by the gods of mythology,
showed them how insane it was to worship such monsters.
His Apollogia, had, however, no effect on the minds of his heroes that had been hardened by the passions,
and a further attempt by the prefect having failed, he was condemned to death at the emperor's orders in the year 322.
Letting his joy at being freed from the bonds of this corruptible life burst forth, Basil raised him of thanksgiving to the Lord,
an interceded for his spiritual flock. Then, having embraced his companions, he presented his neck, saying to the executioner,
do my friend, what is commanded of you.
Far from being satisfied with this execution, Licinius ordered that the body be thrown into the sea,
but the following night, an angel announced to Basil's companions that the saint was waiting for them in Sinope.
When they arrived in that city, the angel appeared to them again and led them to a spot on the coast where his holy relics had grounded.
In spite of its time in the water, the body was found to be incorrupt and giving off a marvelous fragrance.
The head was attached to the rest of the body and the mark of the sword lightly traced by a red line.
The precious relics were then taken to Amacia, where they were placed with honor in the church the saint had built.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.